now if you're a fan of kpop then this
face behind me is probably well known to
you the Korean pop music artist known as
Sun grieve a member of the band Big Bang
has a huge fan following especially
across Asia
well he's now quit kpop after being
implicated in a sex bribery scandal he's
been charged with providing prostitutes
to foreign investors in his private club
here's what the 28 had all had to say
about the charges against him I made
lots of people angry and let them down
once again I want to apologize and I
will fully receive the investigation to
resolve doubts as soon as possible and
for more on this I'm joined on the line
from Seoul by Nick & Co so more she is a
radio DJ and kpop fan herself McCain
good to see you thank you so much for
joining us now you host a radio show and
it's all about kpop so you definitely
know your stuff what was your reaction
when you heard about these charges
against this artist hello thanks for
having me
well personally I was shocked because I
had kept up with kpop for years and I
had interviewed k-pop idols once a month
for the past one in a healthier I had
heard about the tail tales about the
dark side of kpop and so far seeing the
idols I have met and interviewed they
were all so kind and it made me think
that the Telltale's might not be true so
when this new surface it is confirmed
that yes it really existed between all
these many layers how did you feel when
pop idols abused people's trust in this
way I mean it's not just sang Guney
who's been accused of these kinds of
offenses another kpop star Jeong Joon
young has also admitted that he had sex
with women and he filmed them secretly
and then distributed these images so how
do you feel about this abuse of trust
well this has reaffirmed me that as a
fan when we idolize someone
what we are supposed to support is their
talent and we have to be able to spare
their talent and who they are as a
person and about ourselves as a faggins
human in this case what they have done
is criminal and there is no reason for
us to defend them and when someone does
a bad or criminal act that harm others
they should be punished accordingly
regardless of who they are again as a
fan we should differentiate between us
supporting their talent and when we are
at the human shield team and allow to be
enforced
now commented to they've also spoken
about kpop in general and said that this
genre of music generally sexualizes
women and sometimes looks are given a
priority over talent do you think that
is the case with kpop
well in entertainment sector not only
capable we can say that looks will
attract people before their talents do
we can't deny that a lot of people will
get attracted to find out about any
musician or artist after they saw their
looks first and in kpop itself there are
many groups and member of faith groups
which people had saved but quote-unquote
doesn't meet their visual standard yet
they have outstanding talents and if we
are talking about well does that change
the way people look at kpop yes it does
because if we look at kpop ones and say
that kpop is all about looks
we should tell ourselves first that we
shouldn't judge the book based on his
covers when they can cost more radio DJ
and kpop fan speaking to us from Seoul
thank you so much as being us